the creator of Star Trek Gene
Roddenberry was a true visionary the
Starship Enterprise was supposed to be
soaring through space in the 23rd
century by that time the crew of the
enterprise reflected the philosophy that
Gene Roddenberry had Gene Roddenberry
felt that the enterprise was a metaphor
for his starship earth and the strength
of this starship lay in its diversity
people of many different backgrounds
many different cultures many different
experiences many many different
ethnicities coming together and working
in concert as a team boldly going where
no one had gone before and that was
depicted in the makeup of the crew
african-american woman as the
communications chief the captain was a
North American the engineer was a
European and my character Sulu was to
represent Asia the problem he had was to
find a name for this Asian character
from the 23rd century because every
Asian surname is nationally specific
Tanaka is Japanese Wang is Chinese
Kim is Korean and 20th century Asia was
turbulent with warfare colonization
rebellion and he didn't once
suggest that he wanted to depict and
suggest a much more enlightened society
and he wanted to find the name that
suggested all of Asia pan Asia and that
was a real dilemma for him he had a map
of Asia pinned on the wall and he was
staring at it trying to get some
inspiration for the Asian character and
he found off the coast of the
Philippines the Sulu Sea and he thought
ah
the waters of a sea touch all Shores
embracing all of Asia and that's how my
character came to have the name Sulu and
so that's the kind of vision he had
projecting into the twenty thirty
century however I did very privately
bring up the issue of gays and lesbians
and he was certainly as a sophisticated
man Oh
mindful of that but he said in one
episode we had a biracial kiss Captain
Kirk and Laura had a kiss that that show
was literally black out blacked out in
the South Louisiana Alabama Mississippi
Georgia didn't air that our red ratings
plummeted it was a lowest rated episode
that we had and he said I'm treading a
fine tight wire here I'm dealing with
issues of the time I'm dealing with the
civil rights movement the Vietnam War
the Cold War and I need to be able to
make that statement by staying on the
air
he said if I dealt with that issue I
wouldn't be able to deal with any issue
because I would be canceled and I
understood that because I was still
closeted at that time I talked to him as
a liberal rather than as a gay man and I
understood his position on that so
that's the way Star Trek envisioned our
future in the 23rd century but I think
we're getting closer to that utopian
society that Gene Roddenberry visualized
much more rapidly than even the
technology we had this amazing
technology on Star Trek we had this
device on our hip walked all over the
ship and whenever we wanted to talk to
someone we'd rip it off and stir
talking back in the 60s that was an
astounding device no wires attached to
it and now in the 21st century early
part of the 21st century we not only
talk to people but all of the things
that we do there send text messages
watch movies listen to music it's
amazing the kind of progress that we're
making both the technologically and
society
you